And now for you, Scoutmasters.
Hello, welcome to the Scoutmasters podcast.
This is a test for you.
This is a test that Green Bar Bill came up with in the 1930s,
in the edition of the Scoutmasters handbook.
I think 1939.
This is exactly what he wrote.
Get an easy chair and place it in a corner of the troop meeting room
if you, the Scoutmaster, can sink into that chair just after the opening ceremony
and just sit throughout the meeting without a worry for its success,
without lifting a finger or moving a foot until time comes for the closing,
well then your troop is run on the patrol method
and your boy leaders are actually leading.
I like it.
Try it.
Let me know if you passed the test.
Hey, this is podcast number 8.
Hey, welcome back. Good to have you.
I want to say I appreciate all the feedback I've been getting through emails,
through ratings on iTunes, comments on the blog.
Certainly do appreciate it, and on Facebook.
This time around, well, I went a little long this time around,
but I hope you'll think it's worth it.
In Scoutmastership, in seven minutes or less,
we're going to talk a little bit about ten things that adult leaders do
that can be frustrating to your youth leadership.
I'm speaking from experience because I've frustrated many a youth leader in my day.
Next, I have a little story about probably the best 4th of July I ever spent at summer camp.
I think you'll get a kick out of it. I know I did.
We're going to wind up with our theory in the series of moving a troop
that is being led by adults to a troop that is being led by youth.
So let's get moving.
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
You know, I feel like sometimes I get a little bit preachy,
and I want you to understand that the next few minutes,
I'm going to be talking about things that I have done,
and that unfortunately sometimes I continue to do
because I'm as much of a learning curve as my scouts are in trying to figure this all out.
So this is not a missive from an ivory tower somewhere.
This is just my experience and things that I have learned,
sometimes with great difficulty over time.
But I want to talk a little bit about 10 things that we do
that can really be frustrating to youth leadership.
One of them is talking too much.
And this is a guy with a podcast and with a blog,
and I love to talk.
I can talk the ears off of a donkey.
You know, I can talk the horns off a billy goat.
I can talk the feet off an iron pot.
I am a good talker.
But when it's time to talk in the role of being a scoutmaster,
we've got to try and keep it short, direct, and intelligible.
Scouts appreciate brevity and concision in your speech.
You know, when they start to show an unusual interest in the ceiling or their shoes,
you've talked for too long.
I can't tell you exactly what that time is,
but it's somewhere in the two or three minute category.
That's why we have what we call a scoutmaster's minute.
Somebody was really smart when they came up with that
because they know that none of us can.
And now I'm talking too long about talking too long.
All right, let's move on to number two, shall we?
Coercion.
Adults can manipulate circumstances and conversations to bring about the result.
And narrowly defining all the options and the ideas
can be really unfairly coercive.
We have to look for direction from honest discussion with our scouts.
Scouts come up with some very interesting and simple resolutions to difficult problems
when we give them the latitude to do so.
We don't need to coerce them into doing the right thing.
We need to help them discover the right thing
by letting them figure it out on their own.
It really works.
It really does.
Number three is nitpicking.
If it was up to me, I have a certain way that I would like a campsite set up.
I have a certain way that I would like everybody to do everything.
Because, you know, I can be a real nitpicker.
But I'm learning not to stress the small stuff,
not to concentrate on the small stuff,
and to look for the good things that they do
and minimize the shortcomings they have sometimes
and celebrate their achievements.
So I try not to be a nitpicker.
Number four is right in there with nitpicking,
and it's micromanaging every little thing.
Get a map out, show them the point on the map,
and don't tell them how to take every step.
Allow them to discover the talents and abilities
without having to stop every ten minutes
to, you know, give them a minor course correction.
They're going to get there,
but they're going to get there in their way rather than yours.
Number five, this can be a big one.
It's been a big one for me in the past, is anger.
Now, Thomas Jefferson said,
when you get angry, you count to ten before you speak.
If you're very angry, count to a hundred.
It's a dark storm. It'll pass.
You're going to be angry at one point,
especially if it's your son.
I mean, frankly, it's going to make you angry.
And counting to ten,
well, maybe that's talking to one of the other adults first.
Maybe it's just taking a little walk.
It's irresponsible and childish to unload a big, angry load of stuff on scouts.
They're learning,
and they need to have the latitude and the freedom to learn
without being afraid that somebody is going to just unload on them.
Number six is sacrificing the perfectly good for the perfect.
Perfection is not our goal in scouts.
Remember you growing up?
Remember learning how to do things?
It's messy and unpredictable.
Let's not expect perfection.
Let's expect action.
Let's expect moving towards the goal.
Number seven,
and this is a good one,
especially when you're dealing with boys in those adolescent years.
Number seven,
a good way to frustrate boys is by treating honest mistakes
as some kind of horrible crime.
Mistakes are inevitable.
They're desirable.
You want your scouts to make mistakes.
They indicate that they're taking action and that they're growing.
Really,
very few of your problems as a scoutmaster
are going to be from deliberate,
premeditated disobedience or carelessness.
Scouts are going to make mistakes in judgment and action
and seize on that moment
to get on their side
and to be a little introspective
and to help them figure out what happened
and not to punish them.
Number eight is hovering.
You heard of helicopter parents?
How about helicopter scoutmasters?
You know,
scouts need a lot of space.
They need a lot of real responsibility
and they need a lot of autonomy.
They don't need somebody breathing down their necks.
Now,
you have to maintain safety and propriety,
but you can do it from a respectful distance.
Let them play the game.
Number nine
is shifting standards.
Don't change the rules in the middle of the game
or otherwise,
you know,
unfairly shift some kind of fundamental goal.
Every course needs some adjustment,
but no one benefits from
just continuously shifting
the standard around
and then saying that
they didn't achieve something
when they actually did.
Usurpation
is number ten.
How about that for a nine dollar college word, eh?
Usurpation.
Actual responsibility
in a scout troop
for behavior,
for achievement,
and for action
leads to actual achievement
or actual disappointment.
If
the adult leadership
usurps this responsibility
to make things easier
or more predictable,
they compromise
the achievement.
actual responsibility
for behavior
and achievement
and action
leads to actual achievement
and that's why they need to have
real responsibility.
This has to be the truth, folks,
because there is no way
anyone could make this up.
A couple decades ago,
when I was on camp staff,
we used to be able
to buy fireworks
and put them off
for the 4th of July
when the scouts were in camp
for the 4th of July.
Well, you can't do that anymore
and it's probably
a good thing, too.
There are a couple
near misses there
that, yeah,
I wouldn't want to relive.
So, no more fireworks
and we muddled through
for a couple years
with just normal
old campfires
and then there was one year
that I was camp director
that I did the best thing
I have ever done
in scouting.
Oh, it was marvelous.
If I do say so myself.
And I do.
Late last night
when we were all in bed
This old Mary hug
I let her near her shed
When the cow could get over
She winked her eye and said
Be a hot ton
The old town's the night
Fire, fire, fire
Late last night
When we were all in bed
I talked to my maintenance guys
and I said,
find everything in camp
that we need to burn
And we're going to put it down
in a big pile
We have a big field
in our camp
And so we're going to
we're going to have a bonfire
We're going to have a bonfire
like nobody's ever seen before
And it's made the maintenance guys
very excited
And they got very active
and they found piles
and piles of stuff
And they piled up
about 15 feet tall
this bonfire
that was just gorgeous
We had a big giant
American flag
One of our scout leaders
who was in camp for the week
built a bit of a framework
and we hung the big giant
American flag
on this truck
so that it would
totally obscure
the campfire
I mean this was a big flag
this was like
a 20 by 30 foot flag
And so now imagine this
The giant campfire is set up
and the truck is parked
in front of the campfire
and the way that the scouts
come down into the field
they can't see the campfire at all
they just see the giant
American flag
So we built a little tiny
campfire
out in front
of the truck
and we didn't light it
it was just a few logs
oh it was weak
it was really weak
and we bring all the boys down
all the scouts come down
and their leaders come down
and we get them seated
in the field
and it's just about to be dark
and then we introduce
one of our
older camp staff members
as an official
of the BSA
from the northeast region
who's going to come
and talk to us
about campfire safety
and there wasn't
an audible groan
that went up
from the crowd
but there were some
kind of strange faces
in the crowd
so this guy comes out
and he starts
droning on and on
and I mean
this is what he was
instructed to do
he just drones on
about campfire safety
and you can't have
fires that are too big
and blah blah blah
blah blah
I mean a scout's
worst nightmare
so after this guy
is speaking for a little while
now what I had
one of my guys
worked at
you know
he was a student
at a high school
and he was one
of their AV guys
and he took his day off
and he went up
to the high school
and he got this
giant PA system
I'm really not too sure
how he got it
but I'm pretty sure
it got back to the school
safely
so we had this
giant PA system
in the field
and it was covered
with tarps
so nobody really
knew what it was
and so our guy
is up there
droning on and on
about campfire safety
and at one point
we just whip the tarps
off of these huge speakers
and there it is
it's Jimi Hendrix
doing the national anthem
if you're an old hippie
like me
you know exactly
what I'm talking about
and we started blasting
that at ear bleed level
and then the truck
started up
and started to pull
slowly away
revealing a giant
campfire
right
and then
so
earlier in the week
I had talked to
my guy who runs
the camp craft
department
at camp
and I asked him
if he had ever heard
of something called
a flaming ballista
and he was thrilled
with the idea
and so he built
a flaming ballista
now I'm not recommending
this as a program
activity for you
but this work
this was in the hands
of qualified experts
of course
and so
he was about
20 or 30 yards away
from the big fire
the big bonfire
set up
with this flaming
ballista
and what a flaming
ballista is
is it's kind of
a deal where you
launch a flaming torch
again
not recommending
as a program
for you
but
so
he's off
about 20 feet away
and it's just
it's just
perfect
because it's just
beginning to get dark
and so the truck
pulls away
and the scouts
see this
giant campfire thing
and Jimi Hendrix
is blasting over
the speakers
and the scouts
get to their feet
and they start
to cheer
and just as they do
here comes
the flaming ballista
that got launched
and perfect arc
in the air
this flaming torch
and hits that
fire leg
just
right
and the fire
starts to go up
and it goes
up
and up
and that fire
I have a picture
of it
and I'll tell you
something
the flames
were at least
60 feet tall
and the scouts
stood on their feet
and cheered
for about 10 minutes
as this fire
just
began
its glorious path
to celebrating
the 4th of July
oh
what a day
boy scout
so this is the third
and final discussion
we're going to have
about transitioning
a scout troop
from adult leadership
to youth leadership
and this time
we're going to talk
about the patrol
leaders council
so we've overcome
the fears of the adults
we've put the leadership
of the troop
squarely in the hands
of the youth leaders
the scout master
and his assistants
have learned their place
and now we need to
get the patrol
leaders council
up and moving
because a healthy
patrol leaders council
is going to be
the heart of any
real youth led troop
it needs to gather
often
and discuss
the troops plans
and it needs to be
run by the senior
patrol leader
it needs to have
the patrol leaders
in attendance
and it needs to have
a scribe
keep minutes
and it needs to be
pretty official
okay
and it needs to be
free of a lot
of compulsion
or participation
by adults
I suggest that your
patrol leaders council
meets before and after
every troop meeting
the senior patrol leader
always runs that meeting
the scout master
never runs that meeting
they need about
10 or 15 minutes
before the meeting
to check in
and to make sure
that they are prepared
they need 10 or 15 minutes
after the meeting
to check out
and make sure
they're going to
be prepared for
the next week
and to do
a little deconstruction
of the meeting
they've just had
and to do
a little reflection
then I'm going to
suggest that the
patrol leaders council
meets once a month
and I would substitute
that meeting
for a troop meeting
this is what we've done
and it's worked
really well
I'm going to give it
to you as a suggestion
but if they meet
on the troop meeting night
that is directly
after the outing
or event
for the month
then you can also
announce that you
will have
scout masters
conferences
and boards of review
that night
so that that doesn't
interfere with troop
meeting nights
and then
the scouts
kind of get the idea
that oh there's going
to be a board of review
every month
and you can do
various administrative
things that night
and scouts
if they're working
on a special project
or something like that
can attend
but basically
it's set aside
for the patrol leaders
council to get the bulk
of their business
taken care of
and I would train
and mentor them
to start out
pretty formally
in those meetings
because it's hard
to focus
those meetings
it's going to be
a real achievement
for your senior patrol leader
to be able to run
a patrol leaders
council meeting
now as a rule
the scout master
is the only person
of the adult cadre
of leaders
who actively participates
in any meeting
of the PLC
and then
only at the invitation
of the senior patrol leader
I'd like
other adult leaders
you know
to stay away
if they need to
address something
they address it
through the scout master
I would say
that that is a
pretty hard and fast rule
especially in the early stages
of making this transition
we're at the point now
where I can have
assistant scout masters
in the room
as long as they're
quiet and respectful
and they don't interrupt
but you know
if they have a question
they can raise their hand
and those questions
are rare
and this is the way
that we train
our adult leaders
however helpful
or informative
they feel
that they might be
it tends to diminish
the process
of scouts
finding out
some important things
for themselves
the role
of adult leadership
when the patrol leader's
council is meeting
needs to be
clearly understood
and it needs to be
strictly followed
so let's be very specific
about what the scout master
does when the patrol
leader's council meets
can you guess
yes
he listens
you may want to ask
some questions
but you almost never
want to issue
edicts
or you know
present lectures
during this time
I would just ask
questions
and that will help
focus the efforts
of the patrol leader's
council
you know
in forming
a new troop
or in a patrol leader's
council
that's significantly
changed due to
leadership elections
or in the case
of a troop
transitioning
the scout master
may have a somewhat
more active role
but it has to be
measured
and disciplined
and it needs to
be aimed
at a goal
of having
a very inactive role
at the end
of each of
the little
PLC
get togethers
the scout master
should have
an opportunity
to make
some brief
remarks
and
when it's
running smoothly
when things are
these remarks
should be
something along
the lines of
well guys
you seem to have
a handle on
everything
you're doing
a good job
and unless you
have any questions
for me
that's all I have
to say
now that you're
an observer
rather than
a participant
and a listener
rather than
a talker
and a coach
rather than
a player
your observations
and what you
hear
is going to
reveal a lot
of strengths
and weaknesses
in the way
that things
are done
and in
the individuals
that are
doing them
and the way
you work
with this
information
is going
to be
vitally
important
a lot
of times
what we
do
and especially
us characters
who end up
as scout
masters
we kind
of default
to telling
people what
we think
this is
economical
and direct
and effective
but there's
other ways
to communicate
ideas
and to help
people find
their way
remember our
job is to
encourage
critical thinking
and leadership
skills in our
scouts
and to
encourage
that
we can best
accomplish
that encouragement
by asking
questions that
allow them to
discover things
on their own
let's say
you've just
observed a
really chaotic
and poorly
run game
during a troop
meeting
and it's
the patrol
leaders
council
time
after the
meeting
and you're
going to
speak
with your
senior
patrol
leader
and the
characteristic
of this
little
conversation
is you
and the
senior
patrol
leader
are on
the same
side
you're not
putting him
in a position
where he has
to answer
to you
for something
that you
perceive
to be
bad
okay
that's not
what we're
doing here
there may be
a place
for that
but 99.9%
of the
time
put yourself
on the
same side
of the
table
with your
senior
patrol
leader
so the
first question
is
so tell me
a little bit
about the
game
and the
senior patrol
leader may
say something
like well we
were trying to
play a new
game but nobody
was really
cooperating
and my reply
would be well
why do you
think that
was
well it was
definitely a new
game and Mark
was trying to
run it and he
just didn't seem
to know how
to do it
then I would
ask well what
did you do to
fix it and the
senior patrol
leader would say
well nothing
really we just
kind of let it
go
now I'm
beginning to
get an idea
here and
based on my
previous experience
I'm going to
ask this question
I would say was
Mark prepared to
conduct the game
had he tried it
out beforehand
oh gosh no
the senior
patrol leader would
say he just
kind of invented
it on the spot
and then I
would ask
my senior
patrol leader
well how do
you think that
approach worked
and the senior
patrol leader would
say well it was
really a mess
but it was actually
kind of fun too
and Mark you
know has a
decent sense of
humor so he
wasn't too upset
I would ask him
then would you
want to do this
every week
and he might
reply well
not really
because it was
really disorganized
and I would ask
him so how would
you prevent this
from happening in
the future
there was a
time where I
would have just
stepped in as
soon as I saw
this game was
chaotic and
stupid and
tried to fix
it more than
likely it
wouldn't have
been chaotic
and stupid
because I'd
been running
it myself
but now I
don't run
games I'm
watching them
hey now listen
I gotta tell
you if the
scouts were
pummeling each
other with
sticks or rocks
or something I
would step in
and do it
but that wasn't
the case it was
just kind of
chaotic and
dumb
that in my
mind I
didn't step
in try and
stop it I
didn't holler at
anybody I
didn't make a
big giant deal
out of it I
just had a
conversation with
the SPL
afterwards and
I gave him the
opportunity to
think through
and to bring
bring a
solution to it
and I actually
learned a few
things the game
was chaotic and
stupid from my
point of view but
the scouts kind of
enjoyed it anyway
I have to keep
recalling that the
troop meeting and
all of its various
elements and the
games and the
presentations and
things are not
mine to control
I have to
maintain the
focus on what
is the important
thing and what's
the key to this
whole thing about
transitioning from
adult led troop to
youth led troop that's
right I have to
maintain my focus on
my mentoring and
coaching and allow
my scouts to
discover and apply
their skills and
not ever take their
responsibility away
hey thanks for
listening you can
read the scoutmaster
blog at scoutmaster
dot type pad dot com
you can also follow
us at scoutmaster blog
on facebook and
scoutmaster blog on
twitter you can
subscribe to the
scoutmaster podcast on
itunes and feel free
to leave a comment or
a review or a rating
at any of those
places you can email
me clark green with
your comments and
questions at clark
green at gmail dot
com clark has me
c-l-a-r-k-e-g-r-e-e-n
at gmail dot com
and that's about oh
no that can't be it
no gotta read the
disclaimer the
scoutmaster blog and
the scoutmaster podcast
are not official
publications of the
boy scouts of america
nor are they
endorsed or sponsored
by the boy scouts
of america nope
they're just a way
to try and lend a
hand to scout leaders
and maybe have a bit
of fun along the way
sir robert do you
have any good wishes
for the nice people
good luck to you
and good camping
thanks very much
folks
and good luck to you